hey chris hey edwin how you doing good
to see you morgan how are you
i'm good uh chris does this kind of feel
like your baby you know you're starting
in this film it's the first one that the
executive produced
are you excited kind of nervous putting
it out in the world yes
it does it's a great way to put it it
does feel like that it is it is my baby
um and i am nervous in a different way
in a different way i mean obviously
anything that i'm a part of i'm part of
the collaborative team whatever whether
i'm
an acting as a in a you know in a small
capacity or large capacity this is the
most responsibility i've ever had on a
film and so
you you've i feel a little bit more
pressure for this to work and and uh
i'm really eager to hear what people
think and already
pretty excited by the reactions thus far
it's
so entertaining you have nothing to be
worried about it's it's so so good i
loved it so much well i'm gonna be
honest i've asked the rest of the cast
this
they had one person they kept mentioning
if you know there's this alien invasion
who out of the cast do you think would
be the first one to step up and
volunteer to save
the world edwin who do you think
everyone was saying the
first person to step up to say the world
uh i honestly think my character dorian
would
because dorian's just he's he's a gun
hoe
it is or isn't type of guy so you know
at this given point
whether he's saving himself or the world
he just wants some action
pretty much well everyone actually said
you as a person would be the one who
would be the first step out of the cast
to save the world
i would hope so yeah i would not agree i
agree you agree that chris
how does it feel knowing that they
didn't see you first oh i would
i wouldn't say me either me
nah not edward edwin for sure
yeah for sure what are the luxury
accommodations in the future where we're
going i i know how to shoot a gun and i
can run fast you can run so
fast so yeah it was amazing you should
have seen we did this take
after take after take running down this
main street martha street in atlanta
yeah it was cold out and i was like man
i'm 40 but i'm
kicking it i'm like running this is good
i know everyone's running top speed and
i'm like kind of leading the pack
and then they go okay on this one edwin
really take off i was like edwin
what and so he started running he kicked
it into a gear
i was like oh you know what
i didn't know you had another gear that
you could go into i've been sprinting
full out you've been going forty percent
he left me in the dust i was like coyote
and the roadrunner yeah yeah
that's amazing um well chris i do wanna
ask you about uh your
what your thoughts were when you saw the
trailer for the eternals and more
importantly what do you think the
guardians of the galaxy would think
about this new group of superhuman
beings
that's a great question um i think it
looks fantastic
i i think it looks really exciting i
can't wait to see it
i have been a fan of marvel before i was
ever in the marvel family and i continue
to be a fan
even though i'm in the family and uh i
think the guardians would be like a
little concerned
they'll be like okay who's this group
like we're we're a good group
too for saving guys but i think
ultimately you know
um i think we're in awe and and
and we like them and uh so yeah it looks
great it looks really great i'm excited
about that and i'm also
excited to be uh reprising the role of
quill
in guardians of the uh the galaxy three
uh at the end of this year
yeah that's so exciting okay so i just
got the wrap real quick obviously
guardians are known for such an amazing
soundtrack will there be any music from
mouserat
and their new album on the new guardians
soundtrack you're gonna have to just
wait and see because you know
that whole album is dropping i know it
is your fans are freaking out parks and
rec it's coming it's very exciting let's
go this is great i've always wanted that
vanity album i hope that when it goes
platinum i get to have a dis tang on my
wall
[Laughter]
guys such a pleasure getting to talk to
you thanks so much thank you
you